this video is sponsored by none other
than Paradox oh yes it's happening
throughout thousands of years of our
history we built our cities organically
corresponding to our needs and daily
lives Street for narrow and human scale
buildings were close together most
things were within walking distance
which was a necessity for obvious
reasons but then came the 20th century
and with it Mass motorization all of a
sudden things didn't need to be as close
as before why have everything within
walking distance when you can also drive
from the first half of the 20th century
onward we abandoned our traditional
dense human-centric way of building
cities that is by the people for the
people and started designing everything
around the car part of this was a
natural development with course people
are more mobile meaning not everything
has to be fitted within walking distance
the other side of the story was a
massive unrelenting lobbying and
propaganda campaign by the Auto industry
today it's almost Unthinkable that
streets and Roads used to belong to the
people you could just walk out of a
building onto the road and your life
wouldn't be in danger nobody would honk
at you nobody would call the police on
you and so on worst case scenario you
had to dodge the occasional horse escort
or tram but this Millennial tradition of
public space belonging to the people all
but evaporated in the span of a few
decades all thanks to the Auto industry
when the number of cars started
increasing so did the number of
fatalities people still assumed that
streets and Roads belong to them so tens
of thousands would die getting run over
by cars speeding across the city there
were attempts at limiting car traffic
and engine speeds but virtually all
efforts were promptly sabotaged by the
Auto industry people and cars were at an
impasse but people weren't about to give
up on their public spaces that belonged
to them for Millennia this was when the
Auto industry played the Ace of their
sleeve in a master stroke of
manipulation they started financing and
organizing traffic safety education for
children where they learned among other
things to always look both ways before
Crossing because roads belong to cars
not people entire Generations grew up
with this Mantra ingraining the idea
into everyone that public spaces should
be surrendered to the O2 Industries
four-wheeled products car manufacturers
also helped to waste public discourse by
Propaganda by popularizing expressions
like jaywalking back then Jay was kind
of of an insult along the lines of an
oblivious dummy a jaywalker then became
a person who used the roads as we always
have for Millennia it was a way to shame
people into accepting the dominance of
the automobile inside our cities and
unfortunately it worked though back then
today's colossal traffic jams didn't
exist so the scale of the problem wasn't
clear yet people didn't yet know about
induced demand nobody knew how
catastrophic the consequences of over
motorization would be the auto
industry's investment into propaganda
and sabotaging referendums paid them
unbelievable dividends it resulted in a
world where our entire civilization
revolves around their product where
governments mandate that every project
every building every renovation every
family home should have space for their
product is this a great business
Arrangement or what in urban planning
core centralism brought about a tectonic
shift and how we plan and design our
cities instead of the human scale
streets and Roads everything is huge
wide and out of proportions freeways and
Road arteries cut through the urban
fabric valuable land has to be wasted on
parking lots and garages to store Auto
industry products instead of compact
walkable neighborhoods everything is far
apart so walking isn't an option and
today I'd like to talk about the worst
example of this modern era sprawl
the satellite Mall
it's a large commercial area at the edge
of town with malls and big box stores
next to the highway surrounded by
enormous parking lots I'm building this
example of a satellite Mall in City
skylines the city Builder game which is
going to be free to play on Steam
between the 18th and 22nd of May as you
might have heard City skylines 2 is
coming this year so this free to play
might be a good opportunity to get into
the city Builder genre once you try out
the vanilla version definitely check out
the list of basic mods which at this
point comprise an integral part of the
game so these satellite modes are home
to big box stores and Edge of Town
shopping complexes they're near the
highway and usually situated far enough
from the city to be a pain Indies to get
to buy anything other than a car and
this is a problem now I planned on
getting out there and recording some
footage of satellite malls after all
they aren't exclusive to America
unfortunately there is plenty of them in
Europe too but my hometown Leipzig
doesn't seem to have a proper satellite
Mall there's the poundsdorf center but
it's right next to an s-bound station
plus there are tremend bus lines leading
directly to it it's far from optimal but
I wanted to go further I wanted a
stronger example the rule instead of the
exception a proper satellite Mall a
Cathedral of consumerism surrounded by
an asphalt desert built for a sweaty
Boomer climbing out of his oversized BMW
X8 SUV to go sit in a kichi fox German
restaurant for an hour and complain
about having to see black people at the
bus stop every morning during their car
commute around them I see a furious
Karen's overprotective parents with
screaming you'll behave children
underpaid foreign menial workers board
pensioners and everyone's weird cousin
wearing their gas station sunglasses
indoors the air is heavy with the smell
of fast food cheap perfume and recent
divorces okay let's not get too poetic
here you get the picture to show you a
proper satellite mall I left the cycling
Haven of Leipzig and headed down to
Boomer town the so-called city of the
modern chemnitz
10 minutes is a case study of satellite
models and why they're a horrible idea
at the edges of the city there is
Alchemist Center Vita Center nifa Park
and the worst one chemnitz Center and
that's the one we're about to check out
right off the bat there is no convenient
way to get there there is a bus line and
that's fair enough but for a commercial
area of this size you would need a tram
at the very least if cars can get this
much infrastructure subsidized by
taxpayers a tram really isn't much to
ask for and the city will actually put a
tram through here sometime within the
next 10 years almost half a century
after the highway was built and
priorities I guess but according to
Google Maps there is actually a way to
get to chemist Center by train so I did
that with my bike in tow the trip ended
up really nice though the close strike
at the cabinet Center the glitter it
became that I'm the only idiot who
showed up here with a bike if you go to
a satellite Mall you'll do so by car
period why wouldn't you everything it
was built to service your car Centric
lifestyle I couldn't even find a bike
rack so I had to improvise if you look
at a map you can see how much space is
dedicated to cars leaving everyone else
hanging this enormous car capacity he
does nothing but induce demand people
tend to choose convenience and comfort
even when it's objectively harmful to
their health to others around them or to
the environment so the family who would
have normally taken the bus to Cabinet
Center will say oh let's go by car is
that because it's faster and more
comfortable there is more than enough
parking space and Road capacity multiply
this by a thousand and you get dangerous
streets air pollution and constant noise
this includes you as well economics
explained I get that you prefer driving
but you should also think of the
consequences your lifestyle Choice has
on others so this is problem number one
of satellite malls due to their enormous
parking and Road capacities they induce
massive amounts of demand and those cars
don't just come from the highway meaning
city roads leading to the satellite Mall
will also become congested making large
swaths of the city borderline unlivable
and to demonstrate this on my way back
to Leipzig I biked back to the station
along the road and well it was quite the
experience
I really hate these satellite malls how
unreachable they are how sanitized they
are how they're a cheap imitation of
real Lively pedestrian neighborhoods and
this ties into the second issue before
leaving I backed around candidates a bit
and checked out a past Prestige project
the blue Boulevard a fully pedestrian
and bike friendly Street where private
cores are restricted but competitive
Buzz of Cambridge Center the blue
Boulevard was almost completely deserted
satellite malls concentrate huge amounts
of Commerce outside the city sucking
everything else dry a city can only
sustain so much commercial Supply and
satellite mods offer disproportionate
amounts of it and this oversupply leads
to closures and bankruptcies though with
the blue Boulevard the problem goes
deeper namely that the boulevard itself
doesn't lead anywhere and it's not on a
natural biking or pedestrian axis it's
just wedged between two busy roads and
you have to make an active effort to
seek it out if you want to get there but
the blue Boulevard is not the only
problem spot even other satellite modes
are suffering such as the beta Center
there the management is trying to get a
trampoline Hall set up inside to somehow
feel all the abandoned commercial space
and this is the tragedy of the satellite
Mall to a city leadership they might
look appealing as far as tax revenue
goes but what the shiny brochures are
silent about is all the collateral
damage they will inevitably cause now
Adam you might say I agree with what you
say and I do agree that you're a living
God among humans who is qualified to
single-handedly solve every urban
planning issue on the planet
but what if someone needs to go through
the hardware store or the furniture
store to make a big purchase in those
situations you need a car as you won't
take home 100 kilograms of building
materials or furniture by bus and that's
a fair point I'm not advocating for a
complete ban of cars obviously there are
many situations where cars are extremely
practical or even the only viable option
like in some parts of the countryside
what I oppose is the disproportionate
use of and dependence on cars what I
want is to cut back on unnecessary trips
if I only go to a satellite mall to buy
some socks and a pair of jeans and maybe
eat lunch I don't have to drag two tons
of metal and plastic with me even though
I could but while one car isn't a
problem if I'm doing it 2 000 other
people are also doing it which is a
problem my right to comfort and
convenience should not override other
people's rights to Safe Streets fresh
air and quiet neighborhoods though these
days this seems to be the case
unfortunately but I'm happy to say there
is a good solution already Superior to
recurrent core Centric State of Affairs
there is a way to arrange the
aforementioned stores in a non-core
Centric way in Mannheim what I used to
live there is about house hardware store
right in the center easily accessible on
foot by bike or by public transit when I
had to repaint my apartment before
moving out I just showed up by tram got
a bucket of paint and some brushes and
took the tram back home if I want to
make a larger purchase I could always go
there pick out what I need and then have
everything delivered from a Depot better
to have one delivery when make 20
deliveries in one trip then 20 people
all driving to the store one by one and
back Ikea is also experimenting with new
better store formats instead of the
usual big metal box by the highway
they've launched a new five-floor store
in Vienna with no car parking based on
the delivery method I've described
earlier if you want something big you
can pick it out and it will get
delivered to you stores like the
Mannheim ball marked and the Vienna Ikea
became integral parts of the city living
in symbiosis with other businesses if I
go to that Ikea I might also check out
some other local businesses in the
restaurant contrast this with the
satellite mall where you're locked
inside a retail compound at the edge of
town far away from local businesses
stores integrated into the city support
and complement other businesses and vice
versa in instead of leeching up the
center like a tumor like satellite malls
do they also cut back on unnecessary
color traffic not because cars are
banned but because you no longer need
them to do your business and cars are
all well and good these symbols of
freedom and so on until you have to pay
insurance servicing and gas and if cars
are the only option in your city you
don't have freedom you have mandatory
microtransactions forced On You by the
auto and oil industry it's time for us
to stop thinking in Satellite malls and
integrate all that commercial power into
our cities instead we'll get livelier
City centers healthy local businesses
and calmer quieter streets that are safe
even for children and the elderly to get
around on their own thank you for
watching and Jesus Christ I almost died
on my way back to the station seriously
anyway thank you for watching and do
check out my patreon if you wish to
support me making more content like this
and I'll be seeing you next time
please